democrats about to pay a heavy price for
their love affair with woke politics
former presidential candidate once
republican and independent now democrat
michael bloomberg sending them this
warning saying quote absent in immediate
course correction the party is headed
for a wipeout in november up and down
the ballot
and the president's awful numbers not
making the situation any better he's
clocking in at 42
approval in a new poll and that's about
the best we've seen
and republicans now have a nine-point
lead in the generic congressional ballot
i am told we're short on time so go
around the table and overall reaction
but the question i sincerely have is
what would the message dana be of
democrats in the midterm what are you
taking to the voters if i were to have
any democrat that was going to come on
the show i would say do you want joe
biden to come and campaign with you
and i think the answer is going to be oh
no i think he's very busy and he really
needs to stay at the white house and
focus on that
the easiest gig in washington is being a
democratic consultant because the media
does all your work for you at this point
they're starting to find out oh wait
there's actually nothing they're
scraping the bottom of the barrel they
don't have a boogeyman to run against
and so i think michael bloomberg's
absolutely right 2022 is shaping up to
be a year it's very very good for
republicans i think republicans are even
going to win the senate race in vermont
whoa heard you say that for sure how
much do they miss donald trump right now
oh they miss him
and they're trying to rehab him but
he'll just golf doesn't matter and so
they tried to make desantis the
boogeyman but it actually ended up
making decent look better and then
everybody went and vacationed in florida
so that definitely worked and mccarthy
doesn't really show enough leg to get
anybody really after him and and
mcconnell is just so mcconnell there's
really nowhere to really land the glove
so it's either tucker or putin as the
bad guy
and order and
no not right now and and biden doesn't
want to name check tucker and putin only
works if you can tie him to trump but
that's not working and just having putin
as the boogeyman doesn't get any
traction with the left domestically with
partisans so they're out of foils us
we got a lot of foils uh indeed we do uh
geraldo what bloomberg points out is a
simple thing that we all know but
they're just realizing on the other side
of the aisle that when you're spending
time renaming schools right sure instead
of opening them let me go a little bit a
little different direction because
everyone knows how stupid that was and
san francisco
the watershed moment i don't think that
they'll never get stronger than they
were the day before the physical recall
but i want to say how democrats have not
paid any attention to latinos that i
think is numerically speaking that's
going to be the big gap on the liberal
left uk would know more than that more
than me but i mean by ignoring latinos
they already are like what is it for 46
gop 45 democrats i mean that lets
latinos which would take you know the
group taken for uh for granted by uh by
democrats for decades
reagan was right they uh they're
republicans they may not know it yet but
they're republican
katie go ahead back again that's right i
would just say that when you can't
afford to eat as a middle class family
because your grocery store bill has
literally doubled in a year that doesn't
that underpins every single issue and
when you can't fill up your gas tank to
go to work people pay attention to that
especially from a president who promised
not to raise taxes on anybody making
less than four hundred thousand dollars
a year and every single inflation is the
bottom line yeah that's right divorce
check inflation check crime check
borders check cover check
checkmate hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else